listen up if you wanna assert your dominance as a woman say,
in circumstances where another girl is flirting with your man in front of you
here is what you should do!
do not do not be like
“he's taken, he's mine”
don't do that!
this only makes you seem unconfident
or makes you seem like you need to control your man in front of her
no, you don't do that!
instead, what you should do is..
do nothing,
absolutely nothing!
just simply stand there and watch from afar
or right there
just watch/observe
that’s the power move
I've been in situations where randos would just come up to me and my partner
and I'm sure they didn't make the obvious assumption
that the girl right beside him is his woman
they’ll try and shoot their shot
okay what do they do?
they come up to him say “hi
I'm blah blah blah”
touch his arms
start laughing a little too hard at everything he's saying
I know he's funny, he's mine
that's besides the point.
what do you instinctively probably want to do?
Maybe grab a drink and throw it in her face??
but don't! don't do anything
just watch/observe
he's a grown adult man!
I don't need to tell him how to shut it down or when to shut it down
he can do it himself!
We do not need to train grown men good manners
We don't need to tell them how to appropriately react when a girl walks up to them
it’s his responsibility to shut it down and let her know that he's taken
the biggest power move is simply do nothing
ladies just watch/observe
he should be shutting you down!
and if he's not,
then maybe he's not the one.
Maybe, he doesn't deserve to be your man.
never ever force situations
or have to remind your man what he has
he should already know
watch/observe
watch how it plays out
please just stand back
to acknowledge the full situation at hand
you know especially if you're drinking
some things might be interpreted differently
but just watch/observe
So take this advice freely on how to assert your dominance as a woman